Hello everybody, welcome to Tokyo Jungle!
Every time I say this, I think of, do you guys know Atarashi
Gakko?
I say that as if they're not one of the most popular J-pop
artists out there right now.
But I knew them like before they weren't popular.
But they have a song called Tokyo Calling.
Yeah, and so every time I think of Tokyo Jungle, I go, Tokyo
Jungle, Tokyo Jungle, Tokyo Jungle.
Hipster mint.
yeah i have pictures of me going to an event of theirs and
well it was a collaboration in um it was um it was um it was
um i'm checking my instagram it was in 2016.
I saw some people calling this audio jungle too though it's
so funny audio jungle audio jungle
but yeah Tokyo jungle a game that um I know a little about I
played a tiny bit a long time ago uh but excited to play it
because like this game is only on here like there's no way I
mean I think you can also play it on what the Vita but who's
playing on the Vita but um yeah it's like so it's it's only
here so you're seeing it here everybody in 2024 I feel like
this game would be such a great thing to get like a, like a
remaster or something at least, you know.
Vita, Omegalol.
Blast from the past.
I know!
This game is still on my PS3.
And if you were curious, which you probably weren't, but I'm
gonna tell you anyway.
Yes.
Metal Gear Solid 4 is the disc that's in my PS3 right now.
so um yep i could switch at any time where it belongs it'll
never leave yeah it just kind of sits in there being a good
being a good game who would i guess diana i'm shocked you
should be also kyle thank you for the five gifted thank you
so much i do want to preface though today be a shorter
stream because i have a late night meeting so um i have to
be awake and i'm not dying for that can we switch now switch
switch nintendo switch no this is the ps3 um shorter stream
because not playing metal gear but it's funny because i uh
have um I think next week I have a couple longer streams
planned um my I don't know my schedule next week is still
kind mostly undecided um but I have uh some stuff that might
have popped up I don't know I don't know what's going on but
go up thanks for the five gifted thank you outer wilds is
there exactly so that on that in of itself will be a longer
stream i think doom is on sunday that'll be a longer stream
um metal gear you know yeah so yep yep yep does psn still
exist in ps3 i've heard that both psp series and ps3 is in
psn no longer there except for ps4 and ps5 no it is psn is
still there because I literally just bought a Metal Gear
icon right before this.
And, um, yeah.
So, it's still there.
A Metal Gear icon is what I said.
Probably didn't hear me.
I bought a, I bought an icon for my account.
It was 50 cents.
And they had like a whole icon pack of MGS3, MGS2, and Peace
Walker.
Yeah, money well spent.
Yeah, so.
This is cute.
Okay, let's press any button.
Oh, wait.
I think I talked for so long, Mike.
Okay.
So, oh, I can't do story mode.
I was going to say, should I do survival or story mode?
But I can't even do story mode.
Rihakari!
Thank you for the 10 gifted.
Thank you so much.
Oh, also, maybe I shouldn't start yet because I'm waiting
for my food to finish.
I have a...
Actually, how much time is left?
Oh, I didn't set a timer.
Uh-oh.
Wait, when did I put it in?
It's probably fine.
Weird.
Usually stories first.
Right?
Like usually, I wonder if you have to unlock stuff to then
get the...
the story.
Also rare costumes and animal characters.
DLC.
There is one DLC that I know.
Thank you for the another tag of the day.
Thank you, thank you.
Story is like unlockables for specific animals.
I see, I see.
What should we be?
We couldn't, I think there's two at the very beginning.
I think there's a...
and the deer.
Maybe we should be the Shika Noko Noko Koshitan Darn!
Thanks for the fact you dude!
Your streams make my day is better.
Thank you!
Missile.
Well, we can always do both as well.
So, no worries.
Be the dog dog.
Missile Minto.
So, we'll just chit chat for a bit until I remember if my
food is done.
I'm gonna go check on it real quick
Hold on I'm getting worried Hold on, I'll be right back Oh,
oh
Sorry Sorry, that took so long Sorry, sorry, sorry Sorry, I
got a candy That I got in Japan Before, do you guys Do you
guys want to?
Okay, I haven't had this before Um, it's a Shio cider, uh,
uh, uh, salt, salt cider, and I'm gonna try it.
Okay.
I'm nervous.
Uh, what if it's like, what if it, like, pops in my mouth?
Okay.
The outside is, is a powder.
We can chat while we wait immediately leaves.
it was like okay I think it like needed like two minutes but
I wasn't gonna come back and like sit for two minutes and
then leave again I thought that would be silly so but it was
like almost done I thought I think it's done I think maybe I
took it out a little bit early but that's okay okay here I
go thanks for the hags postcard I received in the mail today
thank you Rob oh my gosh though I saw that so many I think
at the post office all the postcards were like so sad by it
though like it has this ugly looking like tire mark on top
of it like they got run over um i think we were talking
about that maybe um uh if anybody wants a reprint we can
send those out but i would have to get them uh i would have
to maybe like we wouldn't have them signed but um uh the
mark goes right over your head on mine yeah that's how
that's how um just a tire mark on your face of course it
would be on my face i did all the work and it's on my face
like i so thought it's garbage and put it in the trash
divorce divorce divorce divorce divorce divorce But yeah,
we're going to do envelopes and stuff for the future too so
that this doesn't happen.
We're really sorry.
It's a learning experience for us as well.
Okay, I'm going to try this candy.
Oh, oh,
it's like really sour.
But, oh, that's fizzy.
Oh, it's fizzy.
Oh, it's wet in my tongue.
Do you hear it?
Can you hear it?
Oh my god.
I can't hear it in my ears but I think it's too difficult to
hear on the mic.
When did it get to the inside?
Oh, we sneak a new copy of the next envelope.
Oh, true!
But like I said, it probably wouldn't be signed because it
took us like days to sign the other ones.
I don't know what's on the inside though.
Oh, ah.
Oh!
Hmm.
It's just a hard candy on the inside.
Did you sign them all at Afkai?
Yeah, we did.
So next time we meet up, we're probably going to have to
sign the next batch.
But I have to order all of them, so.
Okay.
Wow.
It's really hard.
Did you get your MGS Collectors Edition?
No!
I had to sign up for text or for like notifications for
Wario 64.
But they text or they send so many tweets.
Did you get Carpal Tunnel from signing all those cards?
No, actually, surprisingly, it didn't hurt so much.
Oh my gosh, thank you for the pink play.
Thank you.
That was a PSP during the old days.
You were a PSP.
How did you become sentient?
But never have PS3 because the games I wanted to play was
Infamous 2.
Probably another PS3 game.
You know, it's Asura's Wrath and Infamous series also God of
War.
But I played Patapon 2 and Monster Hunter Unite.
Nice!
Wow.
Okay, I eat my real food now.
Maybe I should have eaten my real food before having candy.
I don't like the inside.
I kind of like the fizz.
Because it made me feel things.
It made me feel a little funny.
It makes my tummy feel tickly.
I don't know if I like the crunchy part, though.
I'm 100% going to frame it.
I got lucky in the ink smear.
It's only from Matta's eyebrows and above.
It's a very lovely card.
Ah!
I did notice one thing, though.
This is 100% my fault.
I'm going to put out an apology about it.
But I 100% forgot to include the artist's name.
And I didn't even realize until I was like, I was taking a
shower in Japan.
And I was in the shower and I was like, Oh no!
And Matara was like, what's wrong?
And I was like, I forgot to put the illustrator's name on
the postcard!
I was so upset with myself.
I was so mad.
So I'm going to let the artist know.
And I'm also going to put out an apology because I feel
really, really really bad oh I feel so bad but if people ask
for if we do reruns of them I can put the I can I can put
the artist name on the second one so maybe we will just
include them in the envelope maybe that will be better hmm
yeah maybe but
I was in such a rush to make them at all because you had to
make sure that they It got done in time for off-time.
Okay.
Apology video.
I feel so bad, though.
Would it cost a lot more using envelopes?
I'm not sure.
But it's okay.
But, you know, again, it's a learning.
It's a learning.
And also, I had not to put throw Matara under the bus.
But she did also double check them.
I said, this is what the postcards look like.
What do you think?
And she said, all good.
She didn't say anything either.
So, yeah, let's blame her.
Blame Matarokan.
Yeah.
Fire.
Witchcraft.
I mean, um, burner at the stake.
That's what I meant to say.
I think the most annoying thing, though, will be having to
seal all the envelopes because we'll have to stuff them and
seal them.
That's the most annoying part.
Just checked and I got my postcard, too!
Yippee!
I think the residue is from whatever machinery marks the
postage is okay.
I think so, too.
Because all the pictures that I've seen are very similar.
Like, they all look like a tire scuff mark.
So an envelope should make things okay.
Luckily, most of the art is intact on mine.
Yay!
Actually, at one of my jobs, at my data entry job that I had
a long time ago, I also stuffed envelopes.
When there was no data entry to enter, I was stuffing
envelopes.
So truly, I'm just returning back to my old office worker
life, for real.
Afterlife, I guess.
Does it count as a life?
Even if I'm dead.
But I'm in my afterlife.
But it's an office worker life.
The office worker's not dead.
I don't know.
Those things are weird.
My unlife.
Sorry for easing.
Mm-hmm.
I saw Satoe do a spicy MGS3 cosplay on Twitter today.
My first thought was, would Mint like this post?
But since it's of Eva, I guess not.
What do you mean I love Eva?
I love Eva.
I don't...
The only person I dislike is Huey.
Even Naomi, I like to make fun of her.
Hmm.
He, we deserved worse.
Yeah!
I'm so excited to play Metal Gear this weekend, but I'm also
so nervous.
I'm so nervous.
I feel like people might have expectations.
And then the expectations will really heighten my anxiety.
And then people will be like, oh no, she's so bad.
And I'll be like, wait.
I mean, I've only played it a couple times, truly.
Like, I'm not, I'm not an expert.
Expectation meant down bad for snakes.
But, uh.
Expectation chaos.
I'm even more nervous about MGS2.
oh gosh um european extreme no kill no alarm run
but are you excited for mj3 i'm not there yet mentally
i think i'm just i'm like so excited for delta i'm like
delta
I just want to see Minto have fun Yay Thank you You can get
the brain rot hyperfixation without being good Yeah I mean
mostly There's like a YouTube channel that plays 24 hour
Metal Gear streams And like Maybe like Even when I'm and I
don't have the sound on for it.
It's on for like a good majority of my day.
So I'm just always have it on in the background somewhere or
someplace.
And I'm just, is that your alt account?
George.
Is that his name?
Honestly, I don't remember.
But I just almost always have it on.
so so that's where like i'm always like if i'm like thinking
of metal gear like you know rather than like playing the
games um to to satiate my my brain rot i'm on mercari
looking for stuff and also um on that live stream can
you truly say you play metal gear solid you never got big
boss rank i never got big boss rank Metal Gear Curious
George Not Curious George I did that one time I dressed up
as Curious George Did you guys know that?
I dressed up as Curious George And so basically My friend I
had a friend who Was really into Into like acting and stuff
Like he This was when I was in like elementary school And
he, he played, I remember he played one of the kids in Peter
Pan, but he was like, really, because of that, he was one of
the kids in a college production of Peter Pan.
And so he knew this college well and their acting
department.
No, not the Lost Boys.
It was one of the, it was one of, like, the children that
goes to Neverland.
but anyway um they invited him that college invited him to
dress up for i think it was either like an anniversary of
curious george or the birthday of curious george something
they were like do you want to dress up and do you want to be
the man in the yellow hat and i'm like thinking back now i'm
like why okay hold on but anyways he asked me if i wanted to
be curious But now I'm thinking, why did he ask me that?
Wait, why did he ask if I would be Curious George?
Why wasn't he Curious George?
Why did he think that of all of our friends?
I would be the best fit for Curious George.
Wait a second.
It's so funny too.
I don't talk to him anymore, but my mom still talks to his
mom.
And she even mentioned him the other day.
She was like, I'm gonna go met I'm gonna go meet your do you
remember that old friend you had in elementary school I'm
gonna go meet his mom and I'm gonna have her ask I'm gonna
ask him well I'm not going but I'm gonna have her ask him
why did you ask mint to be curious George but anyway I
remember I remember that day so well because because I was
like a menace.
I was throwing books.
I was climbing on tables.
I was harassing everybody in the library.
I was just like, I'm curious George.
I don't know what curious George is like at all.
I don't know.
But but I remember at one point I was climbing on the table
and I either hit my funny bone or I hit something in my knee
and my vision literally went black I like was seeing stars I
was like oh my god this is it for Curious George Curious
George's birthday and death days is the same day and I
remember I remember just like killing over as Curious George
being like I remember the day so well because I was in so
much pain from that moment
oh god it's the trauma but I have to just remember I also I
got to take off a day of school for that for that moment for
my pain but it was worth it because I got to stand on tables
curious George ends up in the hospital a lot oh no what if
they thought it was real bit or i mean what if they thought
it was a bit i mean what's a tbi i'm scared maybe i
shouldn't have read that out loud you really just have oh
wait you really have just always been like this talking
about
oh a traumatic brain injury what i hit my leg
it uh it transferred it was a full body concussion
Yeah, I had so much fun being curious, George.
Would do it again.
It made me think, like, if I could be a character actor for,
like, a theme park or something, it would probably be so fun
to, like, I want to be Donald Duck.
That was the day Min decided to become a V-Tuber.
Honestly, until I saw the auditions, like, even when I saw
VTubers, I never thought about becoming a VTuber, but it
wasn't until the auditions that I was like, like the Hollow
Live Myth auditions that I was like, I do kind of want to
become, maybe I can become a VTuber.
I love this game.
Yippee!
I'll be playing it.
Don't worry.
Sorry, I'm eating dinner, like, really quickly.
Oh, my God, for, like, a half hour.
I'm so sorry, you guys.
Crunch, crunch, munch.
Sorry.
One more bite.
Pre-game, Zatsu.
Yeah, pretty much.
Okay.
Oh, I just realized you guys can't hear the notifications.
I'm so sorry.
I keep forgetting my congrats on your signature debut at Off
Guy.
Thanks!
I managed to get a signed card from the Bustin Challenge,
and it's so cute.
And I liked comparing the slight variations with friends.
Stop!
Don't do that!
Don't compare them!
I forgot there was a big way.
Blue soup was so...
Tepe pero.
Thank you.
Yeah.
My signature changed over the weekend because I was like, I
had an idea for it, and then it changed a little bit because
of the postcards.
Even probably each postcard, it'll change a little bit.
I wonder who got the hee hee card.
No, it was a hee hee sticker from the panel.
They probably threw it away.
Oh, it's evolving.
What did it end up as?
It's pretty much the same.
There's just a little slight variation.
Mint.
Why was I the monkey?
Also mint.
So I was climbing on a table.
Don't think that mint.
We weren't supposed to pass out the...
the stickers actually.
Apparently a lot of the chat you notice how some of the
signatures have different facial expressions?
Cute.
Stop!
Um, what was I saying?
Oh yeah, at conventions, a lot of conventions don't allow
stickers.
Even like some conventions don't allow um, uh, uh, artists
to sell stickers in like the artist alley even.
But, um, there's like a They're afraid that people will,
like, stick them on, like, walls and stuff like that.
So, when I gave it to the staff, to Off-Kai staff, I was
like, here, I have some stickers for people that come to the
panel.
And they were like, oh, well, I think they still passed them
out, though.
Did anybody who went to Off-Kai and went to our panel, did
you get a sticker?
Please say yes.
Because I spent extra money on it.
I did?
I got both of them.
Yeah, there was mint ones and Matara ones.
Do they keep from selling stickers at Artist Alley or
something?
Or just free stickers or a no-go?
I think you're not allowed to sell them either.
I think.
just woke up.
Thanks for waiting specifically for me before starting Mint.
You're so welcome.
Okay, now we can start, everybody.
Sorry for the delay.
When I went to get a package at the post office the other
day, I pulled the Mata sticker from my wall and sent my
driver's license.
Oh my god.
Wait, why didn't you pull the Mint sticker?
mint sticker instead.
Would you rather be Matara than mint?
I didn't get it.
What do you mean I didn't get it?
Orangey.
Oh, maybe they were random.
They were just kind of giving whoever.
The postcard is so cute.
Looking forward to the next one.
Thanks for bringing more eyes on the Tokyo jungle.
I loved it.
I hope it will get a re-release because I left a silly
accessory.
Silly accessory in your art tag.
Oh, hold on.
Can I check and my art tag.
I'm checking.
I'm going to Twitter.
Silly accessory.
Oh my god.
So first thing I see is a Hawaiian t-shirt.
You guys, some things are not showing up in my...
When did you...
When did you send it?
The accessory.
Oh wait.
Oh, I went to the wrong tag.
My bad.
Some things are not showing up in my...
Oh my god.
Wait, stop.
This is so stupid.
Sometimes I notice that things don't show up in my art tag.
Or like, I'll see things show up.
Like, as like a, you know, you know how sometimes you get
like, oh, this is a related tweet.
But it doesn't show up in my art tag.
Okay, I'm gonna put it on later because, ah, oh gosh, that's
why, oh god, I'm gonna mess up something with, with, with
all my, I'm working on a vertical monitor here, so, because
my current, my other monitor is the game, so,
ghost powers, okay, sorry, I messed up the, you know, the,
the, um, you know, the way that you are able to view me,
otherwise, I would be, I would be transparent, you know.
Okay.
Someone poorly explained this game to me.
You animal.
Survive.
Make baby.
Run from crocodile.
Survive.
Survival.
Here we go, baby.
Hopefully it's loud enough.
Human kind has vanished.
Ooh.
I'm kind of worried because I get really sad when animals
get hurt.
A decade later, Tokyo's familiar landscape has become a home
to beasts.
A jungle.
Ooh!
Pets have turned feral.
Wild animals have escaped from the zoo.
Oh my god, wait, is that a Matsuya?
For real?
Race horses have been freed from servitude.
Ooh, my moose baby!
They're free!
Let's take a look at this brave new natural order.
Uma peon!
Oh my god, that's me!
Tutorial missile!
I'm gonna turn up the audio just a little bit.
Stealth?
Oh no.
Why is that step one?
If you hope to survive, do not allow stronger animals to see
you.
Okay.
But he could smell me, right?
Oh, I'm just a little dog!
Tall grass offers vital cover.
The grass blocks other animals' lines of sight.
Oh, he's so cute.
Oh, oh.
Ah!
Do you think if ghosts count as human cars?
No.
Leaving the grass will expose you!
I'm exposed!
Yeah, don't look!
The game will be too hard if they could also smell you,
maybe.
Reach your destination using the grass to stay hidden.
Okay, the car.
This is just a tutorial, guys.
We're fine.
Can you see...
Can you see me, like...
Oh, oh, oh.
This dog's blind!
Ah!
Oh no!
The wolf's caught sight of you!
Fail!
Okay.
She turned around so fast.
Go, go, go.
Nice.
Oh, okay, good, good.
Oh, he woke up!
He woke up!
Fall back asleep, buddy.
Okay.
We're gonna wait for them to turn around.
Turn around.
Nice.
They won't see me now, right?
If I run.
Run!
Jump!
Oh.
Nope!
Pitiful Pomeranian.
I'm a cat!
Hunting.
Predators live by catching.
and eating other animals.
The hunger gauge shows your current hunger level.
Unless you eat, the hunger gauge will reach zero and you
will begin to lose life.
If an animal's life reaches zero, it will die!
No!
Oh my god.
I know, this is just nature.
Look there.
A rabbit.
Approach it without being seen, then go in for the kill.
Oh my god, I know this is just nature.
Goes on the rabbit without letting it see you.
Oh!
Once in striking distance, an icon will appear to indicate
timing.
Press R1 the moment the bite icon turns red to large.
Strip your prey's bones and eat your fill!
Rules of nature!
Eat.
Oh my god!
I'm a dog!
Combat.
In the law of the jungle, animals must compete for food.
Odd!
Is that a hyena?
The scent of a fresh kill has drawn hyenas.
You can't deliver a killing bite while the enemy is watching
you.
First you must create an opening.
Use the square button to claw and expose the hyena to
attack.
End it with a bite?
Can I eat the hyena?
Doggo, bongo, don't look.
Enemies will attempt to catch you in their own jaws.
If successful, the attack is fatal.
But if you evade it, they are exposed to counter-attack.
When the bite icon appears over the beagle, evade, then
counter!
How do I do that?
Oh, evade!
Ah!
Counter!
You eluded the hyena's jaws.
The hyena is left wide open.
Don't let this champ slip by.
Bite the hyena back.
CQC.
Even victors are rarely unscathed if the enemy has a pack
the danger rises well we'll have our own pack the hyena pack
is just beyond use claw and fang to claim their territory
for your own oh my god defeat all the hyenas
oh shoot two hyenas remain ah oh oh I made yeah
He's sniffing out.
He's sniffing me out.
I'm taking your territory, buddy.
Oh.
Ah!
Oh!
Claw!
Claw, claw, claw!
Oh.
Ah!
Oh my god.
Don't kill me.
Claw, claw, claw!
I can claw you!
There we go.
Woo!
Excellent.
My caution.
There's even a caution level?
Oh my god.
No way.
Shikano-ko-no-ko-no-ko-ko-ko-ko-ko-ko-kositan-tan- Shikano-
kano- Grazers are herbivores.
They survive by eating plants.
They don't have to hunt, but are poor fighters as a result.
Oh my god, there's just mushrooms.
Plants grow in a wide variety of places.
The plant icon on your radar shows their position.
Okay, I see it.
There's even a radar!
Is this just Metal Gear?
plants without being seen by predators.
Okay.
I'm hidden.
I'm hidden, I'm hidden.
Metal Gear but with animals.
Eat two more types of plants.
I think there's only this guy over here, so eat!
I hope he doesn't see me though.
Don't see me.
Okay, good.
Don't turn.
Oh, I just realized I'm kind of big.
So after the tutorial, I'll make myself a little bit smaller
so that you guys can see better.
I ate everything.
One more.
What do you mean one more to go?
I ate it over there.
I ate it!
yourself bigger.
Run!
Oh, I didn't finish eating it.
Eating grass.
Oh my god!
The hyena has seen you!
Ow, ow.
A shika deer stands no chance against the hyena!
Ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow.
Oh my god.
Run!
There.
A stand of tall grass!
Run for cover in the grass before the hyena catches you!
Go!
Danger 100!
Ah!
Oh my god.
If you can enter a stand of tall grass before predators get
too close, you can lose them.
This dumb dog.
This guy is so stupid.
After losing sight of a prey, a predator will try to track
them by scent.
If you are sufficiently far and hidden from view, your scent
will fade.
And the chance you'll be...
found decreases when the danger gauge drops to zero the
enemy will give up and move on just a grass just seems
you've escaped with your life this time oh my god this game
is insane this deer is oh his little tail so cute this deer
barely stood in the grass what a dumb dog Oh.
Breeding.
Oh.
I'm a big dog.
At age 15, an animal's life approaches its end.
They must mate and reproduce or die out.
Oh my god.
I can't die without breeding.
Before finding a female and mating, you must secure your own
territory.
Four marking points exist throughout the Shibuya Station
area.
Oh, we're in Shibuya?
Oh, I recognize it now.
Up there, where the gauge is?
Isn't that where the...
Isn't that where the Starbucks is?
I think.
Use your radar to locate them.
Females?
I have a radar for females?
You can also see their precise locations by pressing start
to view your map.
Mark each of these four points to claim Shibuya Station for
you.
We are out.
Oh my god, female radar.
Hello?
Oh, marking.
I'm peeing.
Hold on.
One second.
I am going to make myself smaller.
Like here.
Hey.
What are you doing in my area?
Clean kill.
I'm not even hungry.
I just did that because I'm a psychopath.
I'm marking territories.
Where's another territory?
Oh, that's a bunny.
It's okay, bunny.
I'll let you live another day.
Is there anybody here?
I see them on the map.
Okay, it doesn't matter.
I can't tell what's a bad animal and what's a good animal,
you know?
Oh, I have a stamina meter!
Oh my god, I just...
realized I just realized I have a stamina meter probably
shouldn't just hop around then over here
see ya hyena and yeah I am gonna eat you delicious oh I'm
gonna eat you till I'm full look down to the boat oh my god
this game is real easy when you're a dog okay last one over
here go dog go mark your territory reclaim the females oh
it's okay I got him rodeo herbivores like hard mode right
now the Shibuya station layer is Now yours to use.
Nice.
Yeah, where's the...
Oh, now we can breathe.
She's in love with me.
Females have arrived following the pheromone trail.
The females have arrived.
Come here.
Use the radar to locate a female and make her your partner.
Oh, boy, I am.
The females have arrived.
arrived yeah get out of here bunny you don't want to see
what's gonna happen here oh oh the bunny wants to watch
never mind there are three grades of mate prime average and
desperate you
guys I'm desperately mating here please give me a chance I
can't oh god but the best will only respond to males of a
certain caliber.
Perform hunts to raise your standing as a male.
Wait.
This golden retriever hasn't reached a sufficient rank to
interest her.
Hunt down prey and feed to refine your skills as a male.
Well, lady, I have something cool to show you.
Come on, please.
I'm desperate.
You need to rank up to mate with that female.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Is that a sleeping cat?
Stop.
No, I'm going to get Doki Bird over here.
Oh, shoot.
She's fast.
Okay.
What the hell?
Oh my god.
I'm stupid.
Hey, hold on.
That's mine.
It's mine.
You.
Oh my god.
The cat's trying to catch me.
Uh, one?
Oops, they noticed me.
I'm so desperate.
I'm giving desperate- Oh, I gotta eat it.
I gotta eat it, that's right.
Yummy!
Excellent.
I'm gonna eat it to the veteran.
What does that mean?
Survival of the fittest.
It's just a game.
Goodbye, Choki Bird!
I'm eating your body!
What else can we get?
Look at her just standing there.
Shikano-ko-no-ko-ko-ko-ko-ko-ko-ko-ko-koko-koko.
Done!
Black Buck.
She saw that, right?
She saw that?
Look, I'm just eating for the thrill of it.
I'm not even eating because I'm hungry.
Hey, am I good now?
I need to rank up still?
How much do I need to kill here?
These guys are fast.
Is that a chinchilla?
Stop.
Oh, no, it's a bunny.
Oh, my God.
Oh, there's more bunny.
Oh, my God, the sheep are hard.
Is that a monkey?
I can eat the monkey.
Oh my god is he gonna go is he gonna like attack me I can't
jump high enough maybe from here to here dang hold on I
think I can make that why can't I kill the birds okay never
mind I give up what else is there come back how far can you
go?
Oh, I'll hide here.
Hold on, the deer are coming, the deer are coming.
Maybe from the front of the truck.
Oh, maybe, maybe.
Ah, gazelle!
Oh, they're like, oh my god, we just witnessed a murder!
I
think I'm good.
Seems you've reached a sufficient rank.
Try approaching the female again.
Oh, hold on.
I'm not done eating.
What the?
I want to get the monkey.
Oh.
You live today, monkey.
Hey.
Why am I so bad at this?
Hey, did you see that?
You see that?
Did you see that?
Let's make babies now in front of these bones.
You met your partner.
The prime female is interested.
Head for your layer together.
Come on, girlie.
Wait, follow me.
I'll kill anything that stands in our way.
Ah!
Oh my god, that sheep is attacking!
It's retaliating.
Is he still coming after us?
Oh, I think he is.
Uh-oh.
wait where's our layer it's upstairs oh my god hey don't hit
my lady like that the sheep wants to join in you and me baby
ain't nothing but mammals so let's do it like they do on the
discovery channel this is it join your partner at your layer
to mate This is so messed up.
After mating, you'll have pups, and generations will change.
Children inherit a portion of the skill their parents
cultivated.
Mate with your partner in the layer, then change
generations.
Come on!
Let's mate!
I'm about to die because I'm an old dog.
Please.
Oh, God.
Birthday golden retriever, too!
Happy birthday golden retriever, dude.
Oh my gosh, there's an elephant and a zebra.
Hunting, feeding, fleeing, mating.
These are the axe.
Oh, I can't remember.
The fight to survive is never easy, but only the victors
live to see where the future leads.
It's the dawn of another day in the Tokyo jungle.
Are those, what kind of birds are those?
Those dinosaurs?
okay so about the r18 text head to
the layer heart barely even know her oh i got a trophy
jungle baby i'm a jungle baby oh now we have story mode okay
okay what do you guys i think maybe for the purpose of the
stream since it's not gonna be super duper long maybe just
survival would be best.
This is a real PS3?
Of course it is.
Survival Unlock Story.
I think story is in chapters.
Oh, wait.
Story is really long.
Story is in short little snippets.
Okay, okay.
So it's in short snippets, but it's pretty long.
Maybe.
Mate first.
Story second.
Very, very short chapters early on.
Maybe we can try it then.
I'm kind of curious.
What kind of story mode could we have?
Mankind has vanished, leaving Tokyo overrun with animals
fighting to survive.
Oh my gosh, it's Hachiko!
So it's the tutorial again?
Human kind has vanished.
Isn't this what we just saw?
This is what we just did.
Missile.
Decade later, Tokyo's familiar.
Yeah.
Wait.
Oh, so we have to do survival to unlock the story.
I thought...
Okay, I understand.
That was my mistake.
Hold on, let me get...
I'll get us...
I'll get us out of here.
Yes.
I just wanted to see Missile again.
Okay.
Okay, well then, it's time for survival mode, baby.
New game.
Multiplayer!
Anybody want to play Tokyo Jungle with me?
Pomeranian.
Shikadir.
Complete the Shikadir challenge.
We got a little piggy!
Porcupine ostrich.
Hippo challenge.
now these are the dlc ones so you could be a red panda what
is that multiplayer mating okay never mind i do not want to
play multiplayer with the crocodile
maybe i should have bought those instead of maybe i should
have bought those instead of him look
at his pants they're all dirty i like how there's the alt
color of pomeranian too and the dinosaurs look he can be a
panda i don't think pandas would live i'm not gonna be i'm
gonna be honest should we try it wait does that mean we can
find a lady you
think if we like Yeah, why is he an herbivore?
Wouldn't he be in...
Maybe he was...
You guys...
I don't know.
Maybe he was vegetarian.
Kind of curious.
I mean, I got him, so...
Oh my god.
That dog should be my pet.
I'm gonna claim...
I'm gonna claim this territory.
He has my own.
This is...
Oh!
He's gonna go!
Look at him!
He's running over to his friend!
Oh my god, I got a trophy.
Don't!
No, no, no, no!
No, no, no, no.
We're fine.
We're chill.
We're cool.
Ah!
This is Legend of Zelda.
Oh my god!
Yes!
Oh my god.
Danger 100%.
We can't let that dog see us.
Oh, we're hungry.
Intake 1,200 cat.
Wait, what was that?
Challenges are triggered by meeting certain conditions.
Completing a challenge will earn you special rewards.
Open the menu.
Have a look at challenges there.
We're a rookie.
Rookie, rookie game.
gangster versus mob boss.
Okay, let's go eat some food.
You don't think the dog will like us, right?
Oh, survival points are a way of ranking your survival
skills.
You'll earn points for hunting, ranking up, taking over
territory, changing generations, completing challenges, and
surviving.
Push your score to the limit and compete in the rankings.
Oh, okay.
Level one crook.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, that's it.
There's lots of food over here.
Eat!
UMAI!
Who's in the grass?
Gotta eat this too.
UMAI!
This is so funny.
I'm gonna pee here.
I love this guy.
So this is what an office job is like.
I've gotten 500.
Nice.
I'm killing it.
Two years, two year old.
What if I leave this area?
I'm kind of scared, though.
He's thriving.
Okay.
There's something over here, though.
There's nothing...
There's no grass to protect me, so we gotta make sure it's
not a crazy ant.
What is that?
I can't...
Is that a rabbit?
Maybe?
Oh my god, our hunger goes down so fast.
Why can't we get stuff out of, like, the vending machines,
you know?
Dogginzaka.
Oh my god.
Jungle 24.
What the hell?
There's a Fujisoba here.
No way.
They actually have Fujisoba.
That's so funny that they're able to, like, actually get the
actual store names and stuff for some of these places.
Oh, it's looking kind of grungy over here.
Oh, it's a dog.
He's protecting the area, though.
You think I can attack him?
Oh, shoot.
Ah!
Oh, God.
Kya!
Sorry, dog.
I gotta eat these apples.
I'm a little salary, man.
Oh, my!
Sorry, dog.
I can't even do anything with them.
It's so sad.
This is my territory.
I'm the most feral thing here.
Sorry, doggo.
Just don't think of it, guys.
Just don't think of it.
This is the rabbit, right?
There was something over here, too.
Like, I wish I could move the...
I wish I could move the camera to see, like...
Let's go hide in the grass.
Then we can see what it is.
Oh, there's...
I think it's a pack of dogs!
You guys, there's no way we'll survive this.
There's no way...
We can't...
Oh, gosh.
A ferocious beast sighted you!
was sighted in Yo-Yo-Gi Park.
Wait.
What do you mean?
Why is it so dark?
You will survive.
Let's stay the hell away from Yo-Yo-Gi-Park.
Oh, it's nighttime.
That makes sense.
This is my area.
This is my territory.
You're hungry!
Oh my gosh, Salary Man.
You just ate some apples.
Could you calm down?
What am I hearing?
Life is decreasing!
Oh, God!
Eat, eat, eat!
Come, come, come, come, come, come!
I need a female, you guys.
He ate some apples last year.
Do you hear that, though?
Oh my God.
I'm gonna get this dog.
Oh no!
Sorry, Beagle.
Sorry, little Beagle.
I'm hearing a lot of noises.
Oh my god!
This is terrifying!
What?
What the Beagle do?
He was gonna attack me!
Probably.
When he wakes up.
I need more food.
Oh, drink one.
Oh, this...
No, we have dysentery now, probably.
Six years!
We're killing it.
What's that triangle on the map?
My!
That can't be healthy.
What is this?
Oh, that's the bird... the birds we killed earlier.
It's not funny, but, you know.
what is that oh it's a chicken this is my mating spot this
is where we will mate what are the yellow wait a second are
the triangles ones that are that will be that will attack us
and then the circles are kind animals maybe that's the case
or something I can't tell
Oh, it's elevation.
Ah, okay, okay.
Oh, I see it.
I see it now.
Oh, my God.
My life is decreasing due to hunger.
I need food.
Oh, my gosh.
We need plants.
Like, pronto.
Oh, my God.
My life is decreasing really fast.
Drink the water.
Oh, my.
Eat.
Why are there so few plants?
Can you eat the chicken?
No.
Oh, we did it!
We did the challenge, everybody!
Let's go.
It's just corpses everywhere.
Hungrier than snake.
That's what I'm saying.
What's over here?
Whatever they are, they're asleep.
I'm just gonna take that then.
Oh, they're a bunch of bunnies.
What is this?
Okay.
Oh, present!
Zookeeper record.
Archives are records left behind by mankind.
Perhaps collecting them will offer some insight into
humanity's sudden disappearance.
Open the menu and read more under archives.
Ooh!
I have to open the menu every time.
Though, it's kind of annoying.
What's over here?
chickens get out of my way chickens where is any food we got
the shibuya station nest mice where's my female where's my
female oh ladies eat the chicken I can't I'm an herbivore I
can only eat grass which oh this grass is not good enough,
apparently.
This grass sucks.
You are hungry, I know.
I know I'm hungry.
Just drink some water, drink some water, drink some water.
Listen, listen, listen.
Oh my.
What about there was one more flag over here, though, wasn't
there?
Hurry up.
Grow back.
It's been nine years.
The grass is still not grown back.
The nest?
Yeah, maybe Maybe our female's waiting there for us.
If there's no other humans, what do we...
What do we...
What do we make?
Who do we...
I have concerns, you guys.
I have concerns.
There's no grass here.
Oh, shit.
I think I might die.
No, no, no.
We must find more food.
Oh, no.
No, you guys!
It doesn't show where any food is, which sucks.
Okay, there was, um...
There was that other area.
If I could... I don't think I'm gonna make it.
Can I drink this?
Oh, here!
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh, thank goodness, thank goodness.
It's just a little bit.
It's just a little bit to get us through.
I've survived 10 years!
Over here, there was another area.
What the?
Defeat 10 animals?
Oopsie.
Oh yeah, we're in Dogenzaka.
I think the dogs will...
Oh, they're gone.
Um, mine.
I need food, please!
Oh god.
Okay, nice.
Any food?
Oh, food.
Food.
Thank God.
Oh my God.
There's food.
Umay.
Oh.
Good.
Okay.
We ate all that we couldn't, which wasn't so much, but...
Oh, God.
Did the dog see me?
I think the dog saw me.
I think I'm gonna take the spot.
Territory of Shibuya Woods is polluted.
Wait.
So is it dangerous to come here?
He can't breathe.
It's a cruel joke!
What?!
No way!
Karoukekan!
Oh my god.
He's distracted.
Matsuya!
Is there food?
Present!
Bottled water!
Wait, are we gonna die at 15 years?
Use.
Nice, nice, nice.
I'm gonna mark this spot.
Yeah!
We have another... Wait, where's my...
Where's my leading lady?
Good night, world.
Maybe I should have slept until morning.
Maybe I should...
Uh...
This is fine.
Probably.
Oh, good.
There's a planet here.
Where is it?
Oh, gosh.
It's really toxic here.
Then I gotta eat.
It's fine.
We'll be fine.
Grab the present?
Pet medicine.
What does this have to do with me?
Oh, it's toxic.
Oh, it's...
Oh, God, it's really toxic here!
Oh, God!
Oh, it's just sheep.
Oh, God.
It's so toxic.
Let's go to the other direction then maybe?
Oh, this...
If we can get to...
There was, like, those other things.
Maybe the...
Maybe the grass grew back.
There's Brittany here.
Oh, there's grass over here.
There's grass.
You guys, we'll live.
We'll live past 15.
I believe.
Umay.
Okay, don't eat all.
Actually, no, I am going to top off.
I am going to top off.
Okay.
13 years.
You guys, we have to find a leading lady.
We have to find a lovely lady.
Oh god, why is it so toxic here?
Wait, there was food and it disappeared!
No!
Food!
Oh my!
Where's our lady?
Why is it all toxic here all of a sudden?
This game is stressing me out.
Oh, it's toxic plants.
Uh oh, don't eat that.
Do you think I'm safe here?
If I keep running?
I think it's okay.
Uh...
We're ladies.
I know!
Females!
I'm in primating condition!
I've I've eaten so many plants!
I've...
I'm gonna have to eat it.
The mat?
Oh!
Oh no!
Oh that really up to her toxicity.
Oh my gosh, I feel like posting on twitter.com right now.
Oh, I feel like posting bad opinions on the internet!
Oh, good.
This one's not toxic.
Am I?
What are they?
Oh, they're chickens.
Oh, this area is like filled with food.
I should have come here from the very beginning.
What's wrong with me?
Also, there's like a lot of animals on second stories.
I wonder if it's all these crows.
You guys, are we about to die?
Can I... Oh, drink the water.
Can I go upstairs, I wonder?
Wizard status.
Look, we've survived 15 years!
What's up here anyway?
Oh, there's just a lion.
Um,
maybe hide in the grass, man.
It's not worth it.
It's not worth the bite.
I don't think we'll survive against the...
Can you beat it?
I'm a human.
I can beat anything.
I took over this world.
I can do it again.
Umai.
Sorry, Terrier.
I'm a beast.
Oh, my bad.
I still have that dog in me.
I've survived 16 years.
Pigies!
Um, hello, Pigies.
We can share this together.
What other, um...
What other...
Challenge list.
Mark seven times.
Intake 2,500 calories.
Head for the Yamano-te line east.
Yamano-te-sen.
Anything else over here?
No.
Iku-zo.
Oh my god.
Look at me.
I'm insane.
Why is it so toxic here?
The accurate IRL mint walk for this office.
This borker is a very nice...
Stop!
Did you do the vocab?
Shut the hell up!
Why is it so polluted here?
That's a cow!
You're fine.
We're friends.
I'm marking my territory.
Yeah, we're friends.
We're friends.
Good morning.
Touch the cow.
Okay, nice.
Why do you have to be so toxic?
The tears of your lips.
I'm on a ride.
You're toxic.
There's more plants.
Oh my gosh, get out of my way, pig.
Oh, I can see the plants on the radar, but...
Just some dead dogs.
Toxic plant.
Good plant.
Please toxic next karaoke.
Oh my gosh.
You're like really pulling my leg here.
Oh my goodness.
Just have to have me...
You're just like saying like, oh my gosh.
Minto, you don't think toxic?
I'm never gonna watch your streams again.
Oh my gosh.
I guess I have to.
If I must.
Whoa, it's like really crazy around here.
What is that?
Oh, it's chicken.
Wait, why is the toxicity going up?
We're in a toxic area?
Uh-oh.
Don't get caught by the vehicle.
Yeah, leave me alone.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Ah!
Oh god.
I think we're in trouble.
I think we're in trouble for real.
Oh.
Get up.
Oh god!
You guys are in trouble!
We're gonna go hide in the grass.
I just wanted to eat.
I just wanted to eat!
Visibility is decreased due to smog.
Uh oh, I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna die here for real.
Okay, leave me alone.
hyenas.
I'm just a little salary, man.
Ah!
Oh, it's so over.
It's so over.
No!
Please!
Let me eat!
I just want to eat!
They can't find me.
But I think I'm going to die here first.
Did they just release their...
They just released...
That lion just like had...
The lion just spawned children and then unleashed them upon
me.
The herbivore mode is so hard.
It's really hard.
I think we did pretty all right.
Generation change points.
is very hard.
KonMinta!
Bashamin!
High score!
New monthly personal record.
I got a world debut.
Wait, how do I...
Let me out of here.
Oh!
There I am!
I'm 898th this month!
What?
There's...
There's over...
How many people are playing this game?
What?
People are playing this game a month!
That is actually so impressive.
This is so impressive.
I'm shocked.
Look, and so many people are little Pomeranians.
896 bots Oh wait, two people 896 bots Ha ha ha ha No I
believe in Cryptid Zero They're a real person And Little
Miss B One, two, three Um Hmm Uh-huh I just realized We
didn't look at the Um The archives That we picked up But um
But, can I still look at them, like, afterwards?
Ghost Bob.
I have to see who number one is, you guys.
Oh, wait.
Start goes to first.
900.
Wait a second.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
The point difference.
No, no, no, no, no.
There's no way.
I think we have a hacker on our hands.
Mm-mm-mm.
But also the Phantom Rice.
There's me!
Daily, I'm 83rd.
This is insanity!
Are you kidding me?
No, Phantom Rise is first!
That might as well be me.
They love playing as the dog.
Okay.
New game?
Imagine hacking the score in this game.
I know.
They're not even top daily.
There's no way.
There's no way that they're that they're that high for the
month if they're not even the top for the day.
Yeah, we're going to use the dog this time.
We're going to be missile.
I actually think I'm okay at this game.
You can unlock other animals and you can also buy them as
DLC.
So.
I'm a dog.
Look how cute I am.
Look at me.
Can I eat this?
No.
Okay.
So now our goal is rabbit.
We got to eat now.
Defeat two animals.
Okay.
I'm not even hungry.
I'm just a psychopath.
I'm eating the crow.
I'm eating crow.
Let's mark this place as my territory so we can get a
cute...
Oh, wait.
So we can get a cute little lady.
This might deplete food stocks later, though.
Maybe.
Oh, I'm...
But...
What are these?
We're a dog now.
We have nothing to fear.
Not even this little tiny bird.
We have nothing to fear!
I can't wait to get...
Um...
Oh, oh!
I pressed the wrong button.
Oh!
Come here!
Come here, bunny!
Oh!
I need to eat!
Please!
Please come home!
Why...
Survive, rabbit survive!
Not today.
Raise rank to veteran.
Raw Pomeranian right now.
Oh, yeah.
I am crazy.
Look at how high this dog can jump.
This dog's kind of crazy.
Look how cute he is.
He's so small and vicious.
I love that for him.
All right, what we're trying to do is we gotta...
Well, first I'm gonna...
I'm gonna take this rabbit out.
Got that dog in him.
I think if anything, there might always be crows around
here.
Maybe.
That's the hope at least, right?
The little chicks.
Oh!
Always check the challenges.
Let's see what our challenge is.
Oh, raise rank to veteran.
We can do that.
Sorry, little chick.
You gotta go.
These four guys are just trying to survive.
It's a doggy dog world out there.
And a dog's gotta eat.
I gotta be faster.
Dogs gotta be fast.
Oh, come on, come on, come on.
Come on, you were so close.
Run, run.
Well, let me mark this first.
Short legs.
They ran into each other.
Come here.
Come here, a little rabbit.
I gotta eat.
I'm gonna be hungry.
Clean kill.
Food is now easily perishable in the blister.
Oh, this is the blistering heat.
Oh, we got a magazine.
My little doggy brain totally needed that.
Can confirm Pomeranians are just like that.
The song is good for Bob and Bob.
my head yeah we gotta get one more to be able to use the uh
the mating and it's already almost four years you guys this
is not good this is not good we gotta go to all the other
side all the way to the other side of shibuya we gotta start
our generations our life we have to mate
I'm gonna eat this bunny.
Ah!
Oh!
He noticed me.
Smart little guy, isn't he?
Where'd he go?
It would be funny if they hid in grass if I couldn't see
them anymore.
For real.
If it was like exactly as it is if the hunters are looking
for me.
Dang, this bunny's fast.
Oh, they're coming back around.
Ah!
Oh, our attack went up!
Nice.
There's a lady.
Oh, you can now use the shibuya station.
Hello, lady.
Oh, she's in love with me.
She's obsessed with me.
She wants to mate with me.
Who wouldn't?
Come on, mama.
Let's go have some pups.
Ara, ara.
Are you guys ready for this?
I don't know if I'm ready for this.
Don't do it.
Look at all our little dogs!
Happy birthday, Pomeranian, too!
Form a pack.
In the event of your death, control will switch to a
packmate.
You can also order packmates to fight by holding the
triangle button.
Oh, wait, how do I switch to old dog?
You cannot use your parents' nest.
So I'm just a baby?
I'm just a little baby?
Oh, wait.
Oh, I guess I thought the triangles...
Or I thought the little dots up were...
Something below.
But I guess it makes sense.
Don't forget to save.
Oh, yeah.
But I can't...
Oh, next pack or next nest we'll have to save.
Who am I?
Yeah, who am I mating with?
Wait a second.
Who am I?
Come on, guys!
Be faster!
Come on!
It's a doggy dog world!
With your pack.
No!
Maybe I should have gone the other way.
This way is really far.
Typically it tends to be poisoned.
No, no.
We're gonna find another suitable lady.
Oh good.
There's some food up here.
There's some...
Wait, what is that?
Is that a dog?
Uh oh.
You guys, I don't know if we can take this guy.
on do you think we can
oh we killed the wolf oh we killed the wolf it's too heavy
to eat or to lift what do you mean just eat it what are you
talking about just just just just just eat it oh no no
there's nothing else here I hear some crows but
I can't, oh gosh, I'm hungry.
Uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh.
Why is this so...
What?
Jump him!
Jump him down!
Yes!
Eat!
Eat him!
Eat him up!
It's dog eat!
It's a dog eat dog world!
What if that was the saying the whole time?
what's over here oh just little baby birds come here come
here chick i gotta eat you i'm sorry
chomp them down chomp them down oh we get a stamina jerky
that's this is a cruel world it absolutely is nothing down
here right oh Okay, we gotta be out.
This is where the... This is where we'll make...
We're big dogs!
I just noticed we turned into big dogs!
Oh wow, there's a lot going on here.
There's monkeys.
Clean kill.
The monkeys are afraid of us though, because we're so
ferocious.
We're a ferocious little pack.
Yes, we are.
Oh my gosh, we keep eating.
Yeah, we got a flirty frame.
Costumes grant the wear, a variety of effects.
Anyone can just get by.
The top dog survives in style.
Change items through the menu screen.
No way!
Wait, items.
Flirty frames.
Sets heart a throb with these sexy spreads.
Missile!
You have me twirling my hair.
You're so flirty.
Wait, what was that?
Items list again?
Um.
I think it was a click up, right?
Just skimming through.
Well, fills you with pep.
And then halt stamina loss for a long while.
Magazine.
Get out of here, monkeys.
Didn't even notice a thing, this stupid...
goat you dumb goat you stupid goat are you hungry or
something why are you standing so close to me this is my
food get your own kill pet medicine nice okay we need to
find oh it looks like it's down here the other um the other
oh wait where are we just kidding I think I thought I know I
thought I knew where we And in honesty, I have no idea.
Wait, where are we going?
We're trying to find...
Oh!
Oh, he ran away from us.
Yeah!
Get his ass!
Jackal!
I'm trying to...
You're in Tokyo.
Oh, thank you.
Why are a pack of Promeranians so cute but terrified?
I know.
Ah!
Oh.
good thing.
There's not fall damage in this.
I'm trying to mark the rest of the area, but hey, they are
monkeys.
Let's see.
Huh, maybe I do have to keep going.
The flag icon is on the map.
Yeah.
Is there a way to zoom in here?
No.
So, there's I just have to keep going to the right then.
Never mind.
I was right the first time.
Head for Shibuya's Shop District.
I'm letting him live because I don't want his pack to...
Triangle of Zoom?
Oh, you're so right.
Thank you, guys.
Oh, Shibuya's Shop District?
It's so far!
There's an event in the Shibuya suburbs.
Maybe we should turn around.
Let's turn around.
Before we go, though.
I'm taking this monkey down.
Sorry, guy.
Oh, no!
What are you talking about?
Why can't I just eat him?
Too heavy to lift my butt.
I mean, my butt's not that big, but...
You get what I'm saying.
Okay.
Oh, no.
No, no, it's too toxic, too toxic.
It's too toxic.
Toxicity is increasing.
We gotta get out of here, you guys.
There's no food here.
Uh-oh.
Why am I gonna be in trouble?
Gosh, oh, no, we're good.
We're good.
Oh, ah!
Oh, shoot.
Come here.
I took him out.
We're eating him.
What?!
Oh my gosh.
What's wrong with us?
I'm just realizing now too how fast the hunger went for the
human.
Like our hunger is actually quite slow for the dog.
Oh gosh, but we're really in trouble.
What's down here?
Take the risk.
Oh my gosh, I missed him!
Take the risk!
Come on!
Oh shit, oh shit, oh shit, oh shit.
I can't die here!
Please!
Let me eat you!
Uh, I think we're gonna die.
I think we're about to die.
Oh gosh!
We went to dog- Oh my god, I'm so sorry.
Your death won't be in vain!
I'll eat your body!
Okay, never mind.
I can't eat him.
even though he's my brother
let me eat my brother let me eat him eat him eat why won't
you oh oh okay why are we picking him up on marking there's
the last mark finally oh there we go
oh we have to go mate I see some I see some willing
participants.
I can sometimes...
Oh my gosh.
There we go.
Sometimes I gotta go in for the attack more so, you know?
Nice.
We're a veteran, so...
I think the lovely ladies...
Oh, don't look at him.
Don't look at him.
Wait!
The desperate female.
Wait, dirty animals!
Touch may pass you there fleas fleas itch so badly that
they'll you'll sometimes be paralyzed bathe in some water or
take medicine to get rid of them.
Oh, we have medicine First story.
Oh wait I have fleas this bitch you gave me fleas you dirty
dog I can't believe you This is what desperation happens
Worth?
No, there's water right here.
We're okay.
Drink the water.
I have no longer have fleas.
Alright, desperate female.
Come on.
She wants me so bad.
I was wondering what the black heart... I thought it meant
she was gonna like...
I don't know.
I thought she was like a...
She was gonna break my heart or something, you know?
Never settle, you guys.
What's this over here?
Oh, a rabbit.
Nah, we're gonna go make some babies.
Oh, oh, shoot.
Where'd he go?
Can I eat this now?
Oh, nice!
Oh, oh, not nice.
Not nice, stop eating, stop eating.
Hey, who are you?
Oh, you wanna...
Oh no, I think this was the other dog!
I think this was the better dog!
We'll be fine.
Let's go eat some of these guys right here.
Clean kill!
I think if I hold down...
Oh, that's when it's telling me...
Do you think my parents are okay?
I just realized.
I haven't seen them in a while.
Do you think my parents are alright?
Do I have to... I'm gonna first save.
Save the game, yes.
They probably died during dog heaven.
Is Mint a desperate?
No!
Oh.
Um.
A new archive has been added.
Continue.
Oh, it just took me out of the game.
That's so funny.
When I saved, it took me out of the game.
Save and quit.
Not just save.
No hard save.
Got it.
That's okay.
We're still mating.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
We are mating.
There we go.
Open up!
Oh my god, my brothers are watching.
watching.
We have a baby!
Happy birthday Pomeranian 3!
What's in the, what's in the...
Oh.
Wait, there's only two of us.
Uh-oh.
The desperate female didn't produce enough.
What if I die?
There's only one of us then.
Wait, mom!
Wait, you guys need to make more!
You cannot use your parents's nest okay what happened to my
other brothers though what happened to them lower quality
women give less babies no way this is so messed up goodbye
parents I'll probably never see you again you'll probably be
dead by the time I'm back here but um just wanted to say
thanks for for a good life maybe.
Yeah, eat that rabbit.
Lessons have been learned.
Wait, are we already a big dog?
That was fast.
No, we're still small.
It's kind of hard to tell sometimes.
We're you say open up your heart open up your heart to me so
that we can make sweet love what are you talking about oh
the heart yes the heart what are you talking about uh-oh
toxic here
now poor guys they just they just they just wanted to be
good Oh.
Hey, where's my brother?
What is that?
What is this?
Oh, it's like a bison or something.
A buffalo.
Oh, R1!
Oh, he's really agile.
Oh my god.
Uh-oh.
I think we're in trouble.
Holy cow!
Holy, no, holy buffalo!
Ah!
I think we're in trouble.
Let's get out of here, brother.
I thought I was going to kill him.
But I did not kill him.
We're still in 100% danger.
We're in less danger.
I'm going to mark this area.
It's mine now.
Ah!
We're in trouble.
This is my area.
This is my home.
This is not your home.
Uh.
Oh gosh.
Oh my god.
Brother!
Brother, I think we're in trouble.
Brother, brother, I think we must leave this place.
Never return.
Brother, brother, I thought we could kill the buffalo.
I thought we could just get his jugular and make it.
Why are you going the same speed as me?
I think we're in trouble.
Fail.
I'm trying to live, I'm trying to survive.
There's no failing as long as I'm alive, Oh no, I'm about to
die.
Oh no, I'm about to die.
Brother!
It's up to you, brother, please!
Oh, the buffalo don't have beef with the brother, though.
Our territory.
The buffalo don't have beef with the brother, though.
I think we're okay.
Oh, we're not.
Okay.
Oh my god, why did I come back?
Why did I come back?
Ghost trick time, so true.
So true.
Load the save.
Wait, actually, though.
I wonder if we should.
19,000 points.
That's gonna put me in the leaderboards, baby.
High score!
You had to go back.
I wanted the territory.
Oh, it deletes it?
Seriously?
That's crazy.
Where am I at?
760th!
Um, put me above Mr. Bios.
Come on.
Put me above.
I know we're tied.
But my name comes first in the alphabet.
This is so rude.
Ass hawks?
At least you're above ass hawks.
Is it because he's a doctor?
I'm not a doctor.
Oh no, I really did delete it.
Wow.
Oh my gosh.
What is multiplayer like?
Hello, Mint.
Love this game was once top four for daily score.
Here's a tip.
Always go for high quality females as they have bigger
litters, more lives, and the next gen inherits more stats.
Have fun.
Thank you, Arb.
I think I learned my lesson after our desperate female.
I think before I even realized she was desperate, it
happened, you know.
What are the stats on the human?
I just realized.
Woo!
They're actually quite high.
Look at the different palm colors.
I want to be an elephant.
I want to be...
Oh my gosh, what is it called?
Not an elephant.
The prehistoric.
What is it called?
Mammoth!
I want to be a mammoth.
Thank you.
This also game...
This game also saves stats so you can breed lion hunting
palms if you play enough.
What?
That's crazy.
I think all females are high quality actually.
Mr. Uncle, you're so right.
You're so right.
How is there a mammoth?
Look, there's even dinosaurs.
Oh, wait.
Where are they?
Here.
There's even dinosaurs.
Look at the speed.
Oh, my God.
That's probably a velociraptor, right?
Holy cow.
The thing is crazy oh my god oh wait maybe not dino not dino
chungus
the hippo seems pretty crazy not gonna lie the hippo would
be a formidable foe i believe dino chungus wonder if we
unlocked any story let's check
Story.
Not a single one.
Nope.
That's okay.
I'm very curious about the archives, actually.
We did collect some, right?
Zookeeper record one.
February 8th, 2027.
That's just a few years away, you guys.
The zoo animals have been restless recently.
are particularly on edge and fights are often breaking out
between between though feeding time has become quite
frightening i think i'll talk to our vet about administering
some tranquilizers veterinary report i've never seen the
animals in such an agitated state while i've been at the zoo
i don't know what could be causing this but one theory is
that they've ingested some sort of chemical that agitates
them making them turn much more savage than before Please
check again to see if there's been any change to their diet.
That's it.
So was it the animals?
Did the animals sense something was happening?
Or was it the animals that caused human extinction?
To unlock story chapters, play survival and collect the
archives on the map.
You can see where they are by zooming out.
Oh, thank you.
Thanks, Jana.
Well, if we read them...
Did then we unlock it?
Nope.
Okay, we need more articles, or more archives, it seems.
More archives, more archives.
But, I'll be honest, guys, I think I'm going to call it
here.
I know it's a really, really, really short stream.
But, um, I said at the beginning of the stream that I have a
meeting that I have to get ready for tonight.
It's kind of a late night meeting, so, um.
But this was a fun, I definitely will want to revisit this,
I think I, um, it's very interesting.
But, uh, so we'll play it again at some time.
It was a good, uh, good introduction, rather.
Maybe I can buy some more animals to have for next time too.
Would love a story mode play there.
Yeah, right, me too.
This is a really unique game.
It is, it's so fun.
I like that it's, it's, almost roguelike in that like you
have to you know start over every time um if you die short
but it was a very fun stream thank you thanks go thank you
thank you this game looks weirdly addicting i know i can
already like i already want to keep going but um i'm gonna
hold off uh just because i think i've overworked myself a
little bit and so i'm like i should rest a little bit maybe
Thanks so much for streaming.
This was hilarious.
Thank you.
Any games are rogue.
Like, if you keep hitting the restart button.
So true.
Try out other old PS3 games, maybe.
Many niche unique games in the past.
And since I have my PS3.
The world is our oyster.
I can play whatever I want.
I wanted to play this for some time.
I'm glad that I could finally play it now, because, like I
said, you can only play it on the PS3, so...
Verily, thank you!
Have you heard about this game?
Oh, heard about this game, but I have never seen it in
action.
Looks really fun, and a little brutal.
Have fun with Doki tomorrow.
Yes, tomorrow I'm collabing with Doki!
We're playing a horror Kusage, so I'm excited about that.
Can't believe they never ported this to PS4.
I really feel like this game could...
I wonder if it's the, uh, if it's the trademark stuff for
some of the businesses in the game.
I wonder.
Um.
I don't know.
Hmm.
This game in MGS4 needs remasters.
So true.
It's on PlayStation Plus 2.
I've played it on PS4, I swear.
Oh, really?
Oh.
But maybe it's not as special as I thought it was.
Submit.
When will you make OG slash cover song?
I don't know.
I...
I have no confidence.
So...
I don't know.
I have some old, old, really old cover songs.
If you ever want to listen to some old songs, They're like
four years old, but that's okay.
Well, maybe one day I'll have an original song.
Maybe if I have the confidence.
We'll see.
Have confidence.
A certain doggle.
Quoted by a certain doggle.
But we'll see.
Um.
Yeah, so I'm sorry, I just realized that I only, you know
what, maybe I can play a little bit longer.
Because I feel like I only did like an hour and a half of
gameplay because I spent half hour talking.
What do you guys think?
One more run?
Should we do one more run?
No need to push yourself.
Fine.
If you don't want to watch me.
I'll leave Mint hell It's holy phantom No No No I want to
watch Let's do one more Let's do one more One more One more
One more One more One more One more One more One more One
more
One more One more.
One more.
Okay.
No going.
Instead of one more run, another 30 minutes of yapping.
Stop.
No, I want to play the game.
Should I try the deer though?
No, I think I'm going to go with the dog.
Let's go with missile.
I changed my mind so quickly.
I made up my mind so, so easily.
One more ghost of me!
Thank you for that, guys.
this time
this time we won't mess it up
clean kill they don't know that I'm a predator she loves us
but we hate her okay
oh look at that look at that turkey go and let's mark here.
Oh, there's a dog in here.
It's okay, I took him out.
This is my territory, other dog.
Turkey?
Yeah, flea shampoo!
Very good.
But we won't get fleas this time.
We're gonna find a lovely, lovely lady.
What is this?
What is the point of this part?
Like, of the scraps there?
I wonder.
What?
Um...
There's here?
Will this mark all of this area or no?
No, we still need one more.
Noise alert of...
Ah, I see, I see.
I see.
I can also jump!
And jumping doesn't even use stamina.
I think it even makes me faster.
it's not so bad i'm gonna take a drip a little sippy oh i
always i always do that okay nice let's keep going
come on let me eat you come on let me eat
oh my god the cries are so sad the cries for help actually i
think i just i think i realized i need to level up we're
we're still a rookie A level one crook.
We need to be higher.
Oh my god, the rabbits are so annoying.
My legs are too small!
Please, let me eat you!
Please.
Let me eat you!
I'm gonna get one of them.
Okay, nice.
You got a dash?
Wait, how do I dash?
How do I dash?
Oh, I almost had him.
Uh-oh.
Is it this?
Oh, but it, like, it, like, makes me stop for a second,
which is...
Oh, oh.
I got him.
No, no, no, no, no.
Eat, eat, eat.
Alright.
Did I do it?
Did I get all of the area?
Did I get all the flags?
Can you cancel...
Can you jump cancel?
the lunge?
I'm not sure.
Oh, I ran past the last one, that's why.
Here it is.
I think I was too preoccupied with food.
Okay, ladies, ladies, ladies, ladies, ladies, I'm not a
desperate male.
I'm just for your love ladies ladies please be clean please
be a good lady please be a good lady bad lady bad lady
desperate sad sad lady I could smell her desperation from
here okay we have to go all the way to the other side before
we do that though we're gonna jump up here for some a little
midnight snack oh
wait maybe now she'll be better because i'm a veteran do you
think or is that not how that works oh wait no no no sorry
it's because the right side says sleep but circle is on the
right side you know that's what gets me about it oh shoot oh
shoot why it should be it should be the left side says sleep
well that's no and that's No, no.
But you press the right button.
So that's why I pressed the right button instead.
Or the left.
Yeah, wait.
Huh?
Cool.
Oh.
Wait, huh?
I think it is a JP thing.
I think it is probably that.
You get it.
You don't have to explain.
Stop confusing me.
okay let's make sure this is a clean lady over here
going for the kill oh see oh it makes you okay i'm gonna
have to yeah you can't dash and jump that doesn't like it
doesn't do anything it's okay though
clean let's excuse me oh she is oh she's rejecting me you
need to rank up mate with that female are you kidding me i
was rejected my oh
oh shoot oh my god i'm
not cool enough i'm just a little pup you guys she wants a
real dog she wants a real a real ruffian
creole kill
BOW BOW!
Oh my gosh.
How does she know how much I've killed anyway, you know?
This one is gonna be huge.
She's gonna be so impressed with this one.
It's so much calories.
I'm a fat pup.
I'm serving bacon.
We'll just keep going, I guess.
We'll mark this territory.
I want to go to the other area, but if the better dog is
over here, then it makes sense to stay over here.
Okay.
Peggy!
Oh!
This game gives me Xbox 360 arcade vibes in a good way.
It's actually quite addictive, I'm not gonna lie.
It's actually very fun.
Karaoke kan.
Like, oh, mark two times.
It's nice.
Oh.
Chichichich.
Take over Shibuya Station.
Wait, didn't I not do that?
Didn't I take over Shibuya?
Oh, my goodness.
Sort of like Dave the Dalai, but...
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, my God.
Win over a mate.
I'm trying.
I'm trying, please.
Wait, there's a mate over here now.
Let's see if she's any good.
Oh, no, don't touch her.
Stay away.
Stay away from me.
Stay away from me, dirty lady.
This pig is going crazy.
This pig.
Piggy.
Piggy, come home.
I need to stop lunging.
I need to start attacking.
No, no, stay away from me!
Stay away from me.
You fiend?
Oh my god.
She's coming closer.
I can see her on the radar.
Ah!
Desperate woman!
Okay.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Oh my god.
It's not a cat.
Wait, where's another lady?
Oh, many ladies.
Is she gone?
Oh no, no, she's still here.
Oh god, oh god.
I have to avoid her.
Avoid, avoid, avoid, avoid, avoid, avoid, avoid, avoid,
avoid.
That's a clip for sure.
Okay, do you think we're good enough now?
Do you think she'll really like us now?
Pet medicine, nice.
Please, love me.
Yay!
The average, the average female.
She's just an average female, you guys, but that's okay.
And here we thought you were the desperate woman.
No!
I jump, you jump.
That's how you know it's real love.
Yay!
Yippee!
Uh-oh.
Wait, I need food.
Oh gosh.
Wait, hold on.
Hold on, ma'am.
May I interest you in a midnight- Uh-oh.
Uh.
Nice.
Okay.
I'm better now.
Uh.
Where's the- where's the- where's the other cat?
I think we're okay.
I think we could just leave.
I think we're fine.
Oh, can I use the nest during combat?
Head for the...
Okay, here we go.
See?
Okay, so mate is on the left side, but I have to press the
right button.
That's why it confused me.
Come here, come here!
Come here, average woman.
Average female.
Dogginzaka.
There's so many of us.
Goodbye, parents.
I'm just like in Pokemon.
I'm leaving.
Leaving the nest at seven years old!
Just like in Pokemon!
Alright.
Now, we go all the way to Shibuya.
Somewhere else.
Shibuya shopping.
Come on, brothers!
Les en van terrib!
I'm the fastest.
of them gang fight against the cats oh oh hello what's
happening our dogs are supernatural they have magical powers
apparently the waiting thing to chat is so long bro I guys
hello thanks for subscribing sorry I have to do that because
sometimes there's like, you know, bots and stuff like that.
What's going on here?
Oh, I think this is a cat.
Maybe, or maybe a bunny.
We need to eat.
Oh, hello.
Ah!
I'm hungry.
I know.
I'm eating.
I'm eating good.
Holy cow.
Nice.
Number one.
Number two.
number three nice oh, uh-oh, uh-oh
this is my territory this is dog territory this is where'd
my brothers go what happened to them oh there they are
doesn't notice me oh shoot Dang it.
It's fine.
We're fine.
You ate the...
I ate my brothers.
Oh.
Attack!
Brethren!
Oh, I don't like killing the kiddies, though.
It makes me so sad.
At least it's cats and not...
What was it?
I can't remember what it was before, but there's a lot of
cats here, you guys.
There are so many cats here.
Oh, nice.
No, it wasn't the water buffalo.
Yes, yes, the water buffalo.
Those guys were crazy.
They were fast.
Oh my god.
The cats are going crazy.
Oh god, oh god.
Fight, dogs, fight!
Oh my god, oh my god!
Fight dogs, fight!
We can take them down!
Oh my god.
Yes!
Down!
We're stronger!
Oh my god.
Get through gang wars, for real.
This turf is ours!
Uh-oh.
Our food is going bad.
Eat up, my brothers!
Before it goes bad, don't worry.
Don't let the food spoil, please.
We worked really hard on this.
It's time to feast.
We will go from veteran to even higher.
We're not even hungry anymore.
We're just insane.
I hear so many cats around.
I want to make here.
I'm gonna claim this territory.
Holy cow!
Oh my gosh.
What's wrong?
Ah!
There we go.
Nice.
Hey, hey, hey.
Feast!
That's a big cat.
These are really big cats.
Hmm.
Mmm, metal.
The poor cat.
I'm gonna go pep.
I'm gonna go love on my cats after this.
I'm gonna go love on them so much.
More!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, it's an entire generation.
No.
This is our territory.
This is our territory!
You guys!
Oh, I think my head blocked it, but I'm a boss now!
I claimed the cat's territory and I became the boss.
I'm a boss.
Oh my god.
We're big boss.
Eat up my brothers.
And then we go find lovely ladies.
How?
How much higher can I get than boss?
Can I get god?
Doggo heaven.
Okay.
I bet this lady over here is really great.
Nope.
Never mind.
Leave me alone.
Stay away.
We're going to go find a great, great...
Oh, oh, whoa.
Just down here.
Drink water.
No fleas for us, everybody.
No fleas for us.
Naomi.
Who's down here, anyway?
Clean kill.
Toxicity is increasing.
Uh-oh.
Wait, but we need to mate.
Do we want to mate in the toxic waste?
Oh my gosh, what if we mate it in the toxic?
That looks to be an average female.
Okay, let's go to the nest.
Yay!
Is it still toxic?
Drink some water, everybody.
Make sure we're hydrated.
Oh my god, there's just dead cat bodies everywhere.
Wait, I didn't kill those, did I?
Oh, there's more cats up here.
Uh, sorry!
Oh!
Oh my god, I thought I was about to die.
Wait, did we kill him?
Oh!
It's R1 to avoid, isn't it?
I thought so.
There was a lot of fighting on it.
Oh yeah, there was a lot of fighting.
You're right.
Alright, let's mate!
Goodbye boss status.
Yeah, right stick.
Yeah, yeah.
Happy birthday.
Palmerian 5!
I've survived 20 years.
No, that's where I was headed.
Oh, man.
It's okay, though.
So I guess you have a 20-year limit.
Or 20-year time limit.
fought for this land, aka me, in another life.
Brothers, we must not take it for granted.
We will go to the shopping district anyway.
Territory of Yamanote Line East is polluted.
Where is that anyway?
Uh...
Oh, Yoyogi Park has a lot of meat!
Uh-oh, the suburbs and the shopping district I don't have
that much meat, but...
I guess we'll just check it out anyway.
Seems to be a lot going on here.
In terms of...
Wait, what was the challenge?
Sorry, I totally missed it.
Mark six times.
Intake 3000 calorie.
Find Bujin.
Reach Dogenzaka.
And find Bujin.
Bujin.
Wait, I have to go all the way back to Dogenzaka?
Are you kidding me?
You know what?
Screw it.
Oh wait, but I need food.
Uh oh.
I need food bad.
What is it?
Drink some water.
Drink some water!
Let's go find something to eat first.
Toxicity is increasing.
Uh oh.
You are hungry!
Uh-oh!
Where's all the food?
Music's kind of bumping now.
I know, right?
Oh, oh, that's not food.
That's a sign.
Uh-oh, I think we're in trouble.
Dog eat dog world.
Oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh.
I can't tell if there's nothing here, if it's low
visibility.
Oh my god, we're gonna die.
We're gonna die!
the toxicity okay i think we gotta get out of here but
there's no food oh god this was a death trap coming here was
a death trap
i think we're in trouble for real drink water our toxicity
with
the taste of your lips i'm on a run you're toxic i'm I'm
very hungry.
I'm gonna die here.
No!
Oh, brother, your death will not be in vain.
We'll reach Dogenjaka, I promise.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, brother.
I'm so sorry.
Oh, I have items.
Oh my gosh, wait.
Okay, oh, we had the bottled water the whole time.
No way, not us having the bottled water and not using it at
all.
Oopsie!
My parents are still up there alive and well.
They could have more children, but they just choose to make
it really difficult on us.
Oh, it's okay, we still have three lives.
I mean, uh...
How is a dog open bottle water?
With his teeth obviously.
Oh, what?
It's a toxic bird!
The bird is too much on.
That bird is literally Twitter.
Oh, there's something over here.
I will eat.
Time to munch!
Oh, it's a bigger dog!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, it's a big...
We're
gonna kill him!
Get his ass!
Brother!
Oh, our toxicity, bro-
Brothers!
No!
Oh my god!
We've lost so many!
It's just us!
Now we're the desperate one!
We're the desperate one!
Oh my gosh, I didn't realize he took two out!
We won, but at what cost?
That was rough.
That was really rough.
I don't get it, because it's dog.
That was really rough!
Damn you, Retriever.
Our entire bloodline was almost wiped out from one dog.
Oh, gosh.
Cracking jokes at her brother's funeral.
He would have wanted it this way.
He would have wanted it.
He loved jokes at his own expense.
So we have to find...
What was the guy's name?
I can't even remember.
Is this where all the monkeys are?
Okay, please.
You know what?
I might have to be the desperate dog and go for the
desperate female.
I'm not gonna lie.
But I don't think we have very many...
Oh wait, that's an average!
No!
Come on.
Clean kill.
I got a pigeon.
Oh.
Eat that pigeon.
Uh, oh.
Once they, once they drop.
Wait.
This is perfect.
We can just farm.
We can just farm points.
Oh, we can just farm points here.
Just you wait.
Average female.
I've killed enough pigeons to really impress you.
What if you brought a carcass to the mate?
What if she watches me?
Hello?
Let's bring it to her.
I have to rank up to be with this female.
Where'd the pigeons go?
Did I kill all the pigeons?
in Tokyo?
Oh gosh.
Oh.
Little chick.
Sorry, little chick.
You are now hungry.
Oh my god, the pigeons wasn't enough.
The pigeons weren't enough.
I need more.
KFP!
It's okay.
They wanted it.
They wanted this.
Is that a cat?
Oh my god.
Eating.
Oh.
What time?
No, we're okay for now.
Did we rank up yet?
Or...
No, we're still a rookie.
These are rookie's numbers.
Real.
What is this?
Oh, there's a monkey!
Come back, monkey!
Oh my god.
Monkey!
Stop monkeying around!
I've got some balloons for you!
I've got some benoos for you!
Where'd you go?
Come back, little monkey!
Run, George!
Why are they so fast?
Okay, we ranked up.
We're a veteran now.
Nice.
Alright, let's go mate.
city is increasing.
Oh gosh.
We're gonna mate in the rain.
In the toxic rain.
Toxic rain.
Come here.
Come here, yo.
How romantic.
It's like in every romance film when they make out in the
rain.
That's literally us.
We're what everybody strives to be.
Like, gosh, I want what they have.
Missile 5.
And Missile 6.
I think I'm...
I think I've desensitized to it now.
Let's go, Pomeranian 6!
Survived 30 years, you guys.
This is crazy.
What is that?
A fat cat!
We're eating that fat cat!
Oh my god, no way.
Garfield Real.
The day after his birthday, even.
So sad.
The...
What's it called?
The thunder is like so loud.
There's nothing here.
Nothing here.
How am I supposed to raise my rank if...
Oh!
Oh my god.
I don't even see the hi-ita!
Holy shit.
Oh!
Ouch!
I was trying to...
Uh-oh.
Time to fight everybody.
Ow!
Don't eat him!
That's my food!
You bastards!
Oh my god.
That's my food!
Oh, shit.
Oh, no!
I got taken down!
Uh-oh.
Uh-uh.
Ah!
Shit, shit, shit, shit, shit, shit.
Oh, yeah!
Yeah!
Ah!
My bloodline is gonna take- Take it down again!
Nice, nice.
Am I all that's left?
I'm all that's left!
Oh, my God.
No, this is bad.
This is so bad.
Oh!
The jackals!
Oh, I didn't even see that guy in the bushes, man.
And then it woke up the other guy.
But you know what?
We took out his family too.
The potato clan.
our highest score i think that wasn't so bad
those are our highest score an eye for an eye
dang i really wanted to find whatever that other guy was
booboo booboo booboo booboo we're 50 570 a second
okay okay why is it why you all have the same number of
points why are you in first huh
i'm 522nd
i'm 145th what is what is that dog
i'm second daily Wait, I'm so close to being first, Ailey.
I am so close to being first, Ailey.
Rip Missile number six.
It was fun while it lasted.
Almost number one.
She's going to go again, chat.
No, no, no.
That was it.
I think I'm good now, for real.
That was a good last run, I think.
That was a good last run.
Dang.
I was trying to also find more of the little things to
unlock more stories, but more of the story.
But my girlfriend Jess's birthday was this past Sunday and
you're her favorite VTuber.
Can I get a happy birthday for her, please?
And thank you for this fun stream.
Thank you, Kuma.
Thank you.
Jess!
I'm sorry I missed your birthday, but happy belated
birthday!
birthday to you happy birthday to you happy birthday to jess
happy birthday to you all right guys well we got further
that last round than before.
This was so much fun.
I'm addicted to this game, for real.
I want to keep playing.
Maybe I'll have to do a really long stream of this.
In fact, 90% of survivors quit before making number one.
I'm a quitter!
I'll see.
It went the wrong direction for the story.
Oh, was it only in the Shibuya area that I could get it?
strict but it was so toxic there i was gonna die out so
that's okay though i had a lot of fun watching you today
thank you i have work tomorrow during your stream so i hope
you have a lot of fun then too good luck with work kinky
thank you so much for the super time thank you guys um so
yeah i'm gonna head out now um otsuminto otsuminto otsuminto
otsubustin otsuminto um have a rest of your night or a great
day whatever time it is for you.
Bye bye.
Thank you for watching.
Thanks for hanging out with me.
Bye bye bye bye bye bye bye.
Bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye